a pg-13 diehard movie yippee-ki-yay
mother [ __ ] yeah it's kind of like that
in a movie lives free or die hard to
live free or die hards the fourth die
hard movie in the die hard franchise
it's been over a decade since we've seen
John McClane that's kind of the theme of
this movie John McClane's a bit older
now he's an analog cop in a digital age
and I like seeing that in this movie
because live free or die hards about
cyber terrorism
Timothy only Fon who's awesome in most
things the same character in most things
but he's awesome in most things he's
going to burn the digital infrastructure
of the American economy to the ground
now it's up to John McClane to stop him
and Justin Long weirdly which again
feeds into the cool theme of this movie
that I personally like or John McClane
gets a new partner it's again not really
a partner he's just a dude who has to
tag along with John McClane like samuel
l.jackson and die hard with a vengeance
only without the f-bombs because hey
this is a pg-13 movie yippee-ki-yay
[ __ ] into the hole pg-13 thing
later right now I'm just gonna stay on
point here okay so you have digital
terrorism in which case John McClane's
like I don't know anything about that
I'm a fish out of water all I know is
guns and fighting cuz I'm a badass cop
but then you got Justin Leung who's like
hey I know computers and hacking and all
that digital [ __ ] but I don't know
anything about guns and being shot at
and I'm a fish out of water with that
situation so you have two guys who are
both fishes out of water but they work
together and they make a pretty solid
team for a situation like this and John
McClane has all his John McClane isms
for a pg-13 movie that is he and Justin
long worked well together Justin Long's
funny because he's also sarcastic and
quick-witted even have a couple hot
chicks this was the first movie I ever
saw Maggie Q in and I was like I am in
love she can kick the [ __ ] out of me
any way she wants and it would be
totally consensual I'll be like do it
again that's cool and you have John
McClane's daughter Lucy in this movie
played by Scott Pilgrim girlfriend
always hot and she's all awesome - you
know she's all feisty and [ __ ] you know
she'd kicked the [ __ ] out of these guys
if she wasn't tied up which isn't a
completely unpleasant prospect you know
I'm just saying of the damsel in
distress type character she is one worth
saving actually probably save herself if
she wasn't tied up and couldn't which
doesn't make any sense whatsoever when
you think about it but moving on and
Timothy Olli font was good in this
movies one of those really smart dude
just like I got a plan and I am just I'm
tearing it all to the ground he's one of
those the pen is mightier than the sword
type of guys you know in a fistfight
between him and McClane he'd lose
terribly McClane's like Penn could be
than the sword that's fine is the pen
mightier than a sledgehammer because
that's what I am and I'm going to beat
you to death if I get my hands on you
why John McClane's awesome and it has
cool action in it you know every
die-hard movie has that action where
you're like that's completely
unbelievable I don't buy that that could
happen and people could survive it this
movie is no exception but it does have
sweet action but there's this one scene
where McLean's in the back of a
semi-truck and it's hanging over a ledge
and he drops down the camera follows him
down and he grabs on to the door it's
all like one shot on a green screen sure
you know all one shot it reminded me of
something that haven't charted I was
like this is why I love uncharted 2 and
uncharted 3 they had things like this
that you play that only does John
McClane look like Nathan Drake in about
20 years because he wears the same [ __ ]
but moments like this and live free or
die hard felt like Uncharted so I
thought that was really cool in terms of
live free or die hard being an enjoyable
action movie it certainly is an
enjoyable action movie but it is a die
hard movie this is where the whole
rated-r versus pg-13 thing comes in the
movie was released theatrically as a
pg-13 movie
on the DVD they made an unrated cut but
on the blu-ray that doesn't even exist
yet I haven't found it anyway but there
are scenes in the pg-13 cut were you
reading people's lips their mouths
aren't lining up with what's being says
here like other they're editing it to be
pg-13 that's stupid I hate that [ __ ]
fanny watch the Unrated cut which is
ultimately the rated-r cut so they can
say the f-word and show more violence
and the blood splatters are digitally
put in when they're saying the f-word
they're off-camera you don't actually
see them cussing and again you read
their lips and what you're hearing isn't
matching up to what they're saying which
then makes you go okay was it film to be
rated pg-13 or rated R both versions
have the same problem just in different
spots
it was either film to be pg-13 or it was
film to be something in the middle that
could be either depending on what the
studio decided which is really funny
that they cut out the yippee-ki-yay
[ __ ] line you're allowed to have
at least one f-bomb in a pg-13 movie you
might as well keep the one that is the
die-hard staple they decided to make it
pg-13 because statistically speaking
pg-13 movies make more money live free
or die hard did certainly make its money
back so you can't argue that but if live
free or die hard was gonna be the last
die hard movie I could be like alright
so you played your hand and you did one
last move to get all the money you could
out of the die hard franchise before an
ending but a good day to die hard is
just right around the corner which makes
me say that making live free or die hard
pg-13 was a dumbass thing to do but
making money is the most important thing
of a business right wrong keeping the
credibility of your franchise I would
argue is the most
thing that in turn will keep the fans
happy and they will give you their money
that's why I hate statistics you know
statistically speaking statistics are
the greatest indicator as to what action
is going to be taken and that [ __ ] does
work if you're counting cards and
blackjack are dealing with pseudo
certainties like that but when dealing
with human beings people the greatest
indicator as to what action they will
take is nostalgia nostalgia and
sentimentality Trump statistics every
time bear with me on this you have a kid
the kid grew up all his life with this
little black and white kitten that
turned into a black and white cat and
the cat dies one day of old age or
whatever he wants another animal now the
studio mindset would be a little
statistically speaking kids like puppies
more than cats so let's have a box of
puppies for him when in reality someone
should be like let's just bring one
black-and-white cat to the store he will
buy that case in point the most
important thing is to give fans what
they expect and desire diehard fans love
die hard movies that look and feel like
die hard movies which means John McClane
is just riddled in blood saying [ __ ]
this [ __ ] that shooting the [ __ ] out of
guys violence and cursing and diehard
ISM this is not a word but it is now but
now that you've compromised the
integrity of the die-hard name by making
live free or die hard pg-13 now people
are looking at a good day to die hard as
that uncertainty they're like I don't
know I guess I'll wait to see what
people think then I might go watch it
bringing in new fans to your franchise
is important but you shouldn't replace
the fans you have with new fans I just
don't get why they made it pg-13 the
fact that the new die hard movies right
at our shows that they don't even know
either to live free or die hard is
certainly a nerf to die hard movie but
as a movie for me and my personal
experience with the movie I found it
enjoyable
I found it cool has really cool action
scenes it has a badass villain John
McClane is John McClane ism's in that
pg-13 kind of way yippee-ki-yay mother
Phi will say I consider live free or die
hard a good time no alcohol required is
that based on your statistics no it's
based on my personal taste which is what
reviews are is it a die hard movie for
die-hard fans no it's not but if you can
look past that you'll actually sit back
and enjoy the movie it's it's not bad
however if you're a die-hard diehard fan
who cannot get over the fact that they
nerfed diehard movie down to pg-13 I'm
not going to tell you you're wrong I so
live free or die hard what did you think
about it did you enjoy it as a movie but
maybe not a die hard movie did you enjoy
it as a die hard movie and an action
movie did you hate it as either in both
whatever you think comment below let me
know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more